You can try a thousand different things,
and you might fail 50% of the time.
You still made 500 things happen.
All right, I think we can get started.
Yali Saar,
it is a pleasure to have you
on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm good.
Thank you for having me.
We both have our coffee and tea.
And we had a fascinating
two hour walk and conversation
here in Tel Aviv just the other day.
And I can't even try to replicate
some of the amazing things
that we brought up.
And I learned so much.
And I can't wait to learn so much more
from this conversation.
But I'd love to focus
these 20 minutes on you,
and who you are,
and your journey.
Focusing specifically
on two incredible initiatives,
Raising the Bar and Tailor Brands.
But before we get to those,
Yali, take me back in time a little bit.
Who is the Yali Saar
and how do you end up running
a multimillion dollar startup
in Tel Aviv?
Okay. So, I'll take you
back to the start.
I started from a little bit
of a different background.
I was an actor here in Tel Aviv.
I did television, I did theater.
I did a lot of children TV.
And then, I found my way into journalism.
Spent some time
as a political spokesperson,
which wound me up actually in marketing.
I moved to the States.
I studied in the States.
And then, I opened up a nonprofit there.
So, I was studying in,
I was studying in Columbia,
Morningside Heights.
And I wanted to see--
Yali, one second.
You jumped way too fast.
How do you go
from being a child TV star
to being a journalist,
and going into politics,
to go and to study in New York
and then creating
a nonprofit for education?
Like I need the thinking process.
So, I think,
a  lot of the things that happened to me
throughout the years
kind of just happened.
I strolled into them.
So, I think that, initially,
like acting was never a thing to me.
And then, one day,
I was walking up the street
and  someone walked up to me and said,
"Do you want to come to an audition?"
And obviously, I didn't think
I might wound up at a basement somewhere.
So I said, "Sure, why not?"
And I went to this audition,
which eventually was an audition
to a theater show,
in one of the national theaters
here in Israel.
So, I started doing that.
I was 13 or 14 back then.
And that just kind of paved my way there.
And from there, I went into children TV
and I did a couple of shows.
The last one we shot over
like 120 episodes.
There were like--
Wait, wait, what?
Yeah, everything you can imagine.
Like calendars
with your pictures on them,
and all of that shit.
Wait, I just need the quick names.
What is the name of that TV show?
So, the last TV show I did
before I completely stopped,
was called "Alifim".
And it's still running today
thanks to VOD.
And then,
I found myself at this point in time
when I was acting
for quite a long time.
And I realized,
you know, I don't know
if this is what I want to do in life.
And back then I was going,
everyone in Israel have to
go through the army.
And they had this program
for military journalists.
So, I applied for that.
And back at the time,
I wanted to start writing.
And there is a magazine,
it's a worldwide magazine,
but also in Tel Aviv called, Time Out.
So, I started writing there
just before the Army service.
My sister was actually
the editor in chief of Time Out Israel.
Really?
Yeah. Lian Matias.
Many years ago.
Wow. Okay.
So, probably I was there
like 14 years ago.
I was the youngest writer there
back in the time.
So young, by the way,
that they made me use
a fictional name.
Wow, that's so cool.
I did that.
I went into the army.
And I started doing correspondence
in just kind of conflict situations.
So, Judea and Samaria
and all around the area.
Easy stuff, nice stuff.
Really complicated stuff.
But things that really get you thinking
and get you to understand
kind of the reality
that you're living in.
And from that understanding,
the minute I kind of finished,
finished with my service,
I got an offer
to join a political campaign
as a spokesperson.
Which I did.
I joined the spokesperson team.
And I did that for,
it was primaries, we lost.
And then, I knew
that I wanted to go to school
in the States.
It was, by the way, back then,
we were also
kind of shooting music videos
for bands here in Israel.
So, I said, I'm going to study
things that are in that field
like arts, management.
I initially went to Parsons.
I did one semester at Parsons.
Then I realized
that I wanted to try something
that was more challenging for me,
for the place that I was in
back at the time.
I managed to get a scholarship
and transferred to Columbia.
Easy.
Easy peasy.
Casual.
And I did that.
And I don't know if you,
you probably,
did you ever have the chance to go
into the campus there?
It's beautiful.
It's a city. It's beautiful.
It's a city within a city.
And it's located Morningside Heights,
which is basically Harlem.
And what I realized is that,
you have this beautiful city
within a city.
And people can actually walk into
a lot of the classes for free.
But none of the people
in the neighborhood do.
So, I started this thing called,
Raising the Bar.
And the idea was
getting top tier professors, anyone,
from like Joseph Stiglitz
was one of the
professors
that was there.
And we had a bunch.
We had like over a hundred.
And we did everything,
from like huge events
of a hundred people,
sorry, of like 10,000 people at a night
to like a hundred bars
throughout the city.
People are speaking
to just like one on one with people.
Basically getting people excited
about education
and coming to school.
Because a lot of the advanced degrees
in the states,
you can actually get a scholarship for.
But if you don't come
from the right background,
you actually don't think
that you have a chance to do it.
So, this is exactly
what we wanted people to understand.
Yali, wait. Before you continue,
I have to
go back
to the junction where,
and excuse me,
but the most important part for me
after the show is to understand
what drives people to do what they do.
And I'm trying to understand,
how does a childhood actor
who goes into journalism, politics,
then moves to the US,
then goes to the Army,
moves to the US for college,
why does he start
a nonprofit for education?
You're not American, right?
You don't have
emotional connection to Harlem.
We have enough problems, you know
of our own that we witnesses here.
Yet you're coming to a new location,
and no matter the location you're at,
you decide
that you have to do something
to help those around you.
Why?
Because there's thousands
of other students that don't have
that thinking process,
and they're coming from there.
So, I'll give you the short reason
and the long reason.
And it's the same reason, by the way,
that a few years later
we started Tailor Brands,
and we got to where we are today.
The short reason is,
you know, I'm hyperactive.
I'm hyperactive,
and I always need to do stuff.
The longer
and more appropriate answer is,
I remember
I went to a meeting
with a career consultant.
You have in every college,
you have career consultants
and you go there.
And I was actually going to,
to understand what I should major in.
And she asked me,
"Okay, what do you want to do?"
And I looked at her and I was like,
it has nothing to do
with what I want to study.
I want to study
because I want to get education,
I want to get knowledge
if I want to do stuff.
And then it kind of hit me.
I can do the stuff
that I want right away.
And then, I started,
I got this notion that
there's no reason to wait for anything.
You can always do the things
that you want to do.
So, I found myself trying to figure out
what I want to do on the weekends.
I didn't want to go out party.
I think that when we discussed,
by the way, about your amazing life,
you also kind of
communicated this urge that
you can go to the parties,
you can go and just hang out with people,
which is great sometimes,
but I always have this urge
to do more things.
To try and figure out
what I can do
that would actually be meaningful
with my time.
And I just saw this amazing opportunity
and I said to myself,
wait, I can make this happen.
There is no reason that this
hasn't happened yet.
And this is how we open up
Raising the Bar.
And luckily for us, it went really well.
And I think that after a year,
we started opening up more branches.
So, right now it has
branches in New York,
San Francisco, Hong Kong,
Australia, New Zealand.
They just opened up
two branches there
because it's covid free.
But, you know,
it's having this urge
to just,
we have this amazing toolset, right?
This toolset is us.
And this is, by the way,
something that you learn as an actor.
As an actor,
all you do is trying to figure out
how you can get more
out of this tool that you've been given.
And as an actor,
you practice mimics,
you practice your body language
and so forth.
But you also have this amazing brain.
Right?
And we all have amazing brains.
And we can conjure
the most brilliant ideas, all of us.
And usually they just die out
on a paper somewhere
or at the back of our heads.
But I realized that
a lot of the times,
the only difference between
having that idea die on the paper
or actually doing something with it,
is not being afraid to fail.
And I think that's the main thing
that kind of pushes me always.
It's the idea that
you can always try to repeat.
And there is a sentence
that my dad used to tell me.
And he said,
"You can try a thousand different things
and you might fail 50% of the time.
You still made 500 things happen."
Or you can debate yourself for years
whether to do this or that,
which one of the ideas
that you should actually go for.
And you end up shooting out two ideas
and you might actually have
a better chances of succeeding 100%,
but still you only get
two things up and running.
So, that's what keeps me going.
It's just like, let's do,
let's do more.
And the worst thing that can happen is,
you're going to fail,
you're going to get up again
and you're going to try again.
That's exactly why
I'm so inspired by this show.
Because when I ask you
why you're the one who did this and why,
whether it was successful,
the answer wasn't because
I had the most insight,
or I was the smartest,
or I was the best looking in the room
and everybody wanted to follow me.
That wasn't it.
Your answer was,
I'm hyperactive
and I need to do stuff.
And I know I'm very privileged
to come from a community
that supports failure,
encourages failure
as a stepping stone for success.
And we all grow up with this,
with those quotes.
Like Michael Jordan,
you miss 100%
of the shots you don't take,
or Thomas Edison failed 10,000 times
before he got that working light bulb.
But at the end of the day,
most people still don't try.
And I think it's a lot because
of the community
that we surround ourselves.
And that if your community
doesn't support failure
and doesn't encourage you
to try and learn from these failures
as a stepping stone,
then it's very difficult.
And I'm completely inspired by,
by what you were just saying.
So, thank you for sharing that.
And I have to talk about Tailor Brands.
Because what you're doing now
is unbelievable.
I visited the offices a few months ago
when you were showing me
a little bit about
what you were doing there.
And one of the first things that you did
that completely amazed me was you,
we've just got to know each other
and you took me to the whiteboard
and you started,
I don't know if you remember this even,
you started scribbling the business plan
and some thinking process
about the next reality of,
of how algorithms are going to help,
going to help us do branding.
And I thought to myself, like, wow.
Like here is this guy,
the CEO of a company
that you have over
a hundred employees, you said, right,
in Tailor Brands,
and you're taking time out of your day
to talk with me
and feeding off of my reactions.
And share to me please.
So, talk to me a little bit
about Tailor Brands
and some of your thought process
as the leader of that amazing group.
So, we have a lot of privilege
working at Tailor Brands.
And I think the main privileges
that I talked about my own urge
to do stuff.
And at Tailor Brands,
we have the privilege
of helping other people do stuff.
Today, Tailor supports--
More than 20 million.
Yeah. Supports over 20 million
businesses worldwide.
Wow. 20 million. Businesses.
No, not just people.
20 million businesses.
This is insane.
Yali, this is crazy.
And we help them set up.
They come to us with an idea.
And initially,
Tailor was just a way
to help them create a logo.
So, the idea was really,
I have two amazing co-founders,
Nadav and Tom,
and initially,
we thought about this idea
of creating an algorithm
that could mimic creative tasks.
So, I was coming from
a world of copywriting;
Tom, my other co-founder,
comes from a world of design;
and Nadav,
comes from a technical background,
and the idea was,
can we try and figure out
how an algorithm
could mimic the same thinking process
that goes in Tom's head,
the same decision tree
that goes into Tom's head
when he's designing a great logo.
So, we initially did that.
And we worked with businesses
to create logos for them automatically.
But what we realized was,
after they create those logos,
the business is still not up and running.
And we started thinking,
okay, how can we create this platform
that is truly kind of like a one-stop
SMB shop.
How can we take them by the hand
and help them make sure
that the idea doesn't stay on paper,
it actually shoots out to the world.
And maybe it fails,
maybe it doesn't fail.
Statistically,
the majority of SMBs will fail.
But it keeps us up and going
each and every day.
And it's amazing.
And obviously, I have to make it parallel
to Raising the Bar.
In one hand,
you're giving opportunities
for education and for growth,
you're breaking down that wall
where you think that
you can't even make it
because you don't have the skills,
you don't have the ability to go there.
And with Tailor Brands,
you're helping people
get their business off the ground
and make those crucial first steps
to even have that ability
to make that jump forward, that leap.
And so actually,
I actually work towards that.
So, what I always love to hear
from leaders,
and entrepreneurs and CEOs is,
what are some of the most
either exciting times
in the whole journey
that I can look forward to
as I start my own startup pretty soon?
And also, what were some
of the most difficult challenges?
A lot of people say that's lonely,
that sort of stuff.
And it's always really interesting for me
and my friends to hear
from somebody who is
a few years ahead of us in the journey.
So, you know, I can only offer insights
on my own journey.
And one of the things that,
we love A/B testing at Tailor.
It's something that we do,
we probably have like
hundreds of A/B tests
up and running at every single moment.
And one of the things that you realize
when you A/B test is that
some of the insights
that you already have
from your prior experience,
they don't mean anything
when you're trying something new.
So, you know, the things
that worked for us,
and in walk
we talked a lot about
having intention, right?
When you're starting anything,
you want to have intention
and you want to be able to do something
that really excites you,
that is
bringing something to the world.
Tailor, because when we started Tailor,
we were 24, I think, 25 at the time,
we really had no experience
in the tech world.
So, our mentality was really about
try, fail, repeat, try fail, repeat,
until you manage to get
some sort of success.
I think that a few things
that I learned along the way is,
a) bringing experience to your team
is often the best way
to avoid all of these failures
along the way.
So, you might be super smart,
you might know
the you're doing the best,
but it's still it shouldn't stop you
and it don't let it stop you
from bringing people with experience
that can help you
kind of avoid future mistakes.
At the same time,
you need to give everyone on the team,
regardless of the experience,
an equal voice.
And this is often the best way
to kind of innovate and find success.
One of the things that
we have at Tailor is, I know that,
whenever we have kind of
a feature or anything else
that we're debating what to do,
my voice counts
as much as anyone else on the team.
As long as the data of someone else
is actually more based
than the data that I bring to the table,
then their idea is actually going to win.
Because title and experience,
they don't really increase
the chances of you being right, right?
The data should actually
do that thing for you.
That's amazing.
And I think that
you can start everything you do
with intention
and do something
that you feel is meaningful
as you know,
because it will make you
run longer for it.
But you need to do
whatever works best for you.
If you have that amazing intention
upfront,
that's amazing.
If you don't
and you want to start running,
start running
and you're going to learn
a lot of lessons along the way.
Last but not least,
Before you continue,
I have to say that I love your comment
about the data and being intentional
because that mindset of,
this is what I'm bringing to the table
my experience and my data,
if you're on my team,
no matter what your title or experiences,
if you can show me different data
that supports your idea,
then you are just as credible as I am.
Because I think that a lot of times
people use a visionary as an excuse
for just going headstrong
into something that has no sensibility.
Now, obviously,
we have examples of people
that went against data
and they were very successful.
But most of the time, it's the data.
I think what you're saying
is absolutely true.
I think that one of the things
that astonishes me is,
how many biographies
do you know of success, right?
We have thousands of those.
Probably like tens of thousands of those.
How many biographies
do you know of failure?
Not a lot, right?
So, what we do a lot of the times
as we project, we say,
okay, Steve Jobs started something
out of a garage.
Exactly, right?
But I think Tailor Brands
started from something of similar nature.
But that's for another story.
But Yali, I'm sorry to cut you off.
Because I promise
it's a 20 minute show.
I wish I called it 30 minute leaders.
But we have to end.
And I have to ask you
my favorite question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Realistically, intolerably optimistic.
You see, you always have to make it
into a really nice phrase.
But can you repeat that
one more time for me?
Realistically, intolerably optimistic.
I might try to adopt that.
Yali, toda raba.
This is wonderful.
I can't wait for our next walk.
I'm learning so much
from every interaction that we have.
So, thank you for the inspiration
and for honestly making the world
a better place.
That's a living example of that.
So, thank you.
Thank you.